the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video
in this video i will go over george r
martin's favorite scene from the show
some of you may already know what it is
but i've never discussed this in a video
myself
as you all know game of thrones is an
adaptation of george r martin's epic
fantasy saga a song of ice and fire
a fantasy story of this size that has
numerous locations and hundreds of
characters
can be incredibly difficult to bring the
life on the screen for a number of
different reasons
this is something george r martin has
discussed himself
he said one of the many great things
about writing a book is he doesn't have
a budget like the show
he can literally write anything that he
can think of
the only thing that limits him is the
size of his imagination
i mean the great thing about writing
books as i as i do now
is that my budget is unlimited i can i
can
write anything that i can think of and
i'm limited only by the size of my
imagination and by the size of
the imagination of my readers but when
you translate it to uh television and
film
you have the realities not only of the
budget which i've mentioned but also the
shooting schedule
now for this reason as well as some
others there are scenes from the show he
likes
and there are some scenes he hates i
recently made a video about the scene
george r martin hated the most some of
you should remember that video
the scene he said he hated the most was
when robert baratheon went hunting with
his brother renly baratheon
as well as barristan selmy and lancel
lannister
the reason he hated this scene so much
is because it doesn't include
all the things he would have included
like more men more horses
and so on and so forth now in this video
i will go over his favorite scene from
the show
this scene was actually slightly
different from the way it was written in
the book
he said it also includes one of the best
changes the show writers dan and dave
made from his books
this amazing moment happened right
before the execution of ned stark
this entire scene is one of the saddest
and one of the most well executed scenes
in television history
in fact i would say this is one of the
defining moments from game of thrones
it's not very often you see a show kill
off their main character in the very
first season
my favorite scene had to be the uh the
end of book end of episode 9 the
execution of
of ned i thought they did that very
powerfully
it was not precisely as described in the
books
but it was certainly moving
and evocative the director did a great
job on it the script writers did a great
job
they added a wonderful grace note which
is when when ned is being led up to the
stairs where he
he sees arya and he says to your end of
the night's watches he passes him he
says bailor
to set in motion urine saving arya
which is not in the books um in the
books you're in just
spots her on his own and takes his own
initiative but it was a great idea to to
give that
little moment that one last kind of
heroic act by
by ned
i think most fans who hadn't read the
books thought ned stark would go on to
win the iron throne
sooner or later unfortunately that never
happened
ned stark was beheaded before the end of
the first season
and this was when fans knew from this
moment on
no one was safe it really is an amazing
scene
even though one of our favorite
characters was executed right in front
of his own daughters
it was absolutely heartbreaking when i
first saw that scene
i remember feeling exactly the same way
rob stark did
[Music]
kill him
every one of them i'll
kill them all
[Music]
now for those of you who still haven't
read the books i want to show you how
george rr martin wrote this scene this
happens during one of arya stark's
chapters
i actually like the show version better
although i will admit
it's not that much different i will
however read it nonetheless because i
know how many of you like it when i make
these kind of videos
it says arya grew frantic forcing her
way to the front of the crowd
she was shoved up against the stone she
looked up at bailor the blessed the
septon king
sliding her stick sword through her belt
arya began to climb
her broken thumbnail left smears of
blood on the marble but she made it up
and wedged herself in between the king's
feet that was when she saw her father
lord eddard stood outside the doors of
the set he was dressed in a rich gray
velvet doublet with a white wolf sewn on
the front in beads
but he was thinner than arya had ever
seen him his long
face drawn with agony he was not
standing so much as being held up
the cast over his broken leg was gray
and rotten
the high septon himself stood beside him
a squat man
gray with age and ponderously fat
wearing long white robes in an immense
crown of spun gold and crystal
that wreath his head with rainbows
whenever he moved
clustered around the doors of the sept
in front of the rey's marble stage
were a knot of knights and high lords
joffrey stood out among them
dressed in his crimson silk and satin
with a gold crown on his head
his mother stood beside him in a black
morning gown slashed with crimson
a veil of black diamonds in her hair
arya recognized the hound
wearing a snowy white cloak over his
dark grey armor
with four of the kingsguard around him
she also saw
varys the eunuch gliding among the lords
and soft slippers in a robe
and she thought the short man with a
silvery cape and beard
might be the one who had once fought a
duel for her mother
she's referring to littlefinger who
fought brandon stark
in there in their midst was sansa
dressed in sky blue silk
with her long auburn hair washed and
curled arya scowled
wondering what her sister was doing here
why she looks so happy
a long line of gold cloaked spearmen
held back the crowd
commanded by a stout man in elaborate
armor all
black lacquered and gold filigree his
cloak had the metallic shimmer of the
true cloth of gold
when the bell stopped ringing a quiet
slowly settled across the great plaza
and her father lifted his head and began
to speak
his voice so thin and weak she could
scarcely make him out
everyone behind her began to shout what
and
louder the man in the black and gold
armor stepped up behind father and
jabbed him sharply
you leave him alone arya wanted to shout
but she knew no one would listen she
chewed her lip
her father raised his voice and began
again i am eddard stark
lord of winterfell and hand of the king
he said more loudly
his voice carrying across the square and
i come before you to confess my treason
in the sight of gods and men no arya
whimpered
below her the crowd began to scream and
shout
insults and obscenities filled the air
sansa had hidden her face in her hands
her father raised his voice still higher
struggling to be heard
i betrayed the faith of my king and the
trust of my friend robert
i swore to protect and defend his
children
but before his blood was cold
i plotted to murder his son
and seize the throne for myself
[Applause]
let the high septon in baylor the
beloved and the seven bear witness to
the truth of what i say
joffrey baratheon is the one true heir
to the iron throne
and by the grace of all the gods lord of
the seven kingdoms and protector of the
realm
a stone came sailing out of the crowd
arya cried out as she saw her father hit
the gold cloaks kept him from falling
blood ran down his face from a deep gash
across his forehead
more stones followed one struck the
guard to father's left
another went bouncing off the
breastplate of the knight in the black
and gold armor
a few of the king's guards stepped in
front of joffrey and cersei
guarding them with their shields her
hand slid beneath her cloak and found
needle in its sheath
she grabbed it hard by its grip
squeezing it harder than she had ever
squeezed
anything before please gods keep him
safe she prayed
don't let them hurt my father the high
sept and knelt before joffrey and his
mother
as we sin so do we suffer he said
in a deep swelling voice much louder
than father's
this man has confessed his crimes in the
sight of gods and men
here in this holy place rainbows danced
around his head as he lifted his hands
in request
the gods are just but
beloved baylor taught us they can also
be merciful
what is to be done with this traitor
your grace a thousand voices were
screaming
but arya never heard them king joffrey
stepped out from behind the shields of
his kingsguard
my mother bids me let lord eddard take
the black
and lady sansa has begged for mercy for
her father
he looked straight at sansa then and
smiled and for a moment
arya thought that the gods had heard her
until joffrey looked back to the crowd
and said
but they have the soft hearts of women
so long as i am your king treason shall
never go
unpunished sir
bring me his head the crowd erupted
and arya felt the statue of balor rock
as they surged against it
the high septon grabbed at the king's
cape and varys came rushing over waving
his arms
even the queen was saying something to
him but joffrey shook his head lords and
knights moved aside as he stepped
through
tall and fleshless a skeleton in iron
mail
the king's justice dimly as if from far
off
arya heard her sister scream sansa had
fallen to her knees sobbing hysterically
sarilan climbed the steps of the stage
arya wriggled between balor's feet
and threw herself into the crowd drawing
needle she landed on a man in a
butcher's apron
knocking him to the ground immediately
someone slammed into her back
and she almost went down herself bodies
closed in around her
stumbling and trampling on the butcher
arya slashed at them with needle
high atop the stage sir ellen gestured
and the knight in black and gold gave a
command the gold cloaks flung lord
eddard to the marble
with his head and chest out over the
edge here
you an angry voice shouted at arya but
she spun around
shoving everyone aside squeezing between
them
slamming into anyone in her way a woman
stumbled and arya ran up her back
cutting to both sides but it was no good
no good
there were too many of them no sooner
did she make a hole than it was closed
again
someone buffeted her aside she could
still hear
sansa screaming cyrillin drew a
two-handed greatsword from the scabbard
on his back
as he lifted the blade above his head
sunlight seemed to ripple and dance down
the dark metal
glinting off an edge sharper than any
razor ice
she thought he has ice her tears ran
down her face
blinding her and then a hand shot out of
the crowd and closed around her
arm like a wolf trap so hard that needle
went flying from her hand
arya was lifted off her feet she would
have fallen if he hadn't held her up
as easy as if she were a doll a face
leaned in close to hers
don't look a thick voice snarled at her
i i i
aria sobbed the old man shook her so
hard her teeth rattled
shut your mouth and close your eyes boy
dimly as if from far away
she heard a a noise a soft sighing sound
as if a million people had let out their
breath at once
the old man's fingers dug into her arm
stiff as iron
look at me yes that's the way of it at
me
sour wine scented his breath remember
boy
arya saw the matted greasy hair the
dusted black cloak that covered his
shoulders
the hard black eyes squinting at her and
she remembered the black brother who had
come to visit her father
know me now do you there's a bright boy
he's spat
they're done here you'll be coming with
me and you'll be keeping your mouth shut
when she started to reply he shook her
again even harder
shut i said everyone in attendance was
beginning to leave
as they drifted back to their lives but
arya's life was gone
numb she followed along beside yorin
yes his name is joran she did not recall
him finding needle
until he handed the sword back to her
hope you can use that boy
i'm not she started he shoved her into a
doorway
thrust dirty fingers through her hair
and grabbed it yanking her head back not
a smart boy
that what you meant to say he had a
knife in his other hand
this chapter ends after it says as the
blade flashed in her face
arya threw herself backward kicking
wildly
wrenching her head from side to side but
he had her by the hair
so strong she could feel her scalp
tearing
and on her lips was the salt taste of
tears
well ladies and gentlemen now you know
how this scene was written in the book
as i said before it's not that different
from the show
now arya was a little more aggressive in
the book version but other than that
the scene basically unfolds the same the
minor changes dan and dave made were
actually
excellent it was also beautifully
executed in the show
which is why george r martin looks at
this as one of his favorite scenes
how did you feel when you first saw this
scene and what do you think of it now
almost a decade later as always i have
to thank all of you for watching my
video
i hope everyone has a great day i will
see you again
very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
you